I
it's a pleasure to introduce jean-paul
Schmitz as the keynote speaker for today
and he is the chief scientist at who but
Buddha media is also the founder and CEO
of a ten better pages and he's going to
talk today about dealing with complexity
thanks hope
wait until I have said something but as
so let me introduce you a little bit who
I work for so you get an idea why I feel
that I can't talk about complexity I'll
try to talk for maybe 40 minutes and
then have questions afterwards so
basically the group is called habitable
immediate owned by one guy started a
hundred years ago over 100 years ago has
only had four CEOs during that time so
that I think is is a good thing and also
a sign that we don't like complexity i
started in printing with magazine
international and digital you may know
if you if you live in germany you may
know some of these brands bullet digital
was founded in 93 it participated
actively in the development of the
internet few people know that we
actually try to buy Netscape in 95 we
developed into a group of 40 companies
and about two or three billion in
revenue depending on how are you exactly
count it it's about 55,000 people with
thirty percent growth year-over-year of
about fifteen hundred engineers so we
are constantly hiring we cover pretty
much all advertising models that you can
find on the internet so we have a lot of
experience with also the big data issues
that are faced with advertising in fact
we are the largest owner of the seventh
largest advertising network in the u.s.
called glam and I think we number two or
so or three in Germany matching
recommendation systems also big data
problem review sites like holidaycheck
which are also interesting data problems
content less relevant for data ecommerce
search very relevant for for big data
social networks like zing and
marketplaces so why our chief scientist
so that's my title we another CTO we
have many CTOs we noticed that people
attended to get stuck in the technology
of their founding so I have this little
game that I can always tell when your
company is founded by looking at your
code
and it's very precise it's like carbon
dating it's very very very nice little
game we have similar problems over
different places simultaneously which we
don't mind at all but it's a bit stupid
if no one knows that they're being
solved simultaneously engineer gets
stuck to their product until they have
to leave because if you want to do green
a green field approach of something you
often have to quit your job which is not
a good thing and certain hiring is
easier the central level but the real
reason is that there's way too much
complexity and that's the reason why you
need someone like me I'm a hacker since
the late 70s studied philosophy in
econometrics because computer science
was really not cool at the time I
studied it was not even possible
sometimes to study computer science i
joined border in 94 on a machine
learning hack if you know boda we did
they had a actually the name word that
comes from a magazine which had sewing
patterns which looked like very
interesting and complicated drawings and
I actually tried to use machine learning
to learn how to build them learned a few
lesson doing that it was working
technically but no one liked it I've
been the CTO and the CEO of what a
digital and then a technical board
member and I actually went to Stanford
to study real computer science so I'm
officially a big data guy from Stanford
so normally I should know what I'm
talking about and I'm a chief scientist
and actively developing products and
teams again for Bora so now to the
problem what's the problem people get
stuck they get stuck before they get
successful so many startups simply never
get to the point where they're doing
what they were planning to do they get
stuck as they get successful they get
stuck after they get successful and even
when people don't get sucked themselves
someone else makes them stuck and even
if you're the greatest sometimes some
code from 1995 that you wrote we'll get
you stuck again and mostly that's
because of complexity so what is
complexity I've come up with I think
it's my definition but
feel free to use it is complexity is
whatever present you or someone else
from doing the right thing now or in the
future right so it's not about
necessarily numbers of lines of codes
it's not about using assembly language
versus Piton it's not about using stuff
that appear difficult to you because you
just learn it last week it's really
about whether what you have done today
is going to prevent you or someone else
from doing the right thing in the future
and simplicity is the opposite is if you
build something that allows people in
the future or yourself in the future to
do the right thing when you know what
the right thing is right because it's
easy to do that when you know what the
right thing will be but if you don't
know it's a bit difficult so creating
complexity is very easy that's the
problem and making things simple is very
very difficult an ability to deal with
change is a litmus test of your level of
complexity so if you as many of our
companies if you it become obvious that
you have to give you an example from two
thousand three or four we had the
largest used bookstore in the world that
we sold to Amazon and it became obvious
that we needed to have a very simple URL
scheme for Google to be able to find
books in us but we had thousands of
versions of harry potter and we wanted
to have a URL that would say
abebooks.com / harry potter and have all
the books they're ranked by some kind of
thing and have we will find it
unfortunately in the early two thousand
people decided that Java was very cool
and it would be even cooler to have a
website with only one URL all right and
then everything would be a session and
the ability to adapt to the fact that
Google you know understandably required
a unique URL for a concept it took them
two or three years to adopt right so
that's complexity even though the code
was not necessarily particularly
but the fact that you couldn't adopt a
knob vyas change was a sign that your
system was too complex so simplicity in
that definition is a prerequisite for
agility that's pretty obvious it's also
pretty wicked for reliability that's a
well-known concept from 70s I think our
and Dykstra we're the first ones to work
out formally what the relationship
between simplicity and reliability with
years it's a prerequisite for it's a
prereq for scalability and it's a
prerequisite for pretty much everything
right but it's not easy and convenient
in fact people often make this kind of
connection so just one but basically
simplicity is difficult and it's related
to understanding right so it has nothing
to do with with easy it's actually very
difficult and the word complexity or I
guess you can it is a word in English
called complexing which is to intertwine
and to interweave stuff and you know you
can import the hairball into your code
very easily renaming it or adding in the
direction doesn't necessarily fix the
problem right complexity arising so in
practice this is a more practical thing
you have a small team great ideas good
tools and a lot of understanding because
you're doing something you truly
understand and you're implementing it so
there's no complexity at that level but
your code base grows people issues
people base grows understanding issue
arise you start to implement stand-ups
and meetings and all again is well in
la-la land but there's a Gorey like
growing in the in the room do people
come on board but they can't figure out
why you've done something before you
they can't seem to figure out you know
the learning curve is too steep
everything gets really difficult the
fondant icky leave because they're
burned out and yearn for simplicity and
starting over again
guru comes and advice etc etc until
Google basically eats your lunch because
they are big and simple so they there
are some theoretical science of
complexity this is more serious i think
is what i just showed you large number
of components large number of
interconnections are well known many
irregularities so many exceptions long
descriptions which is called kamagra of
complexity is if this the smallest
description of your of what you are
trying to do well the longer the
smallest description is the more complex
you thing is in large numbers of
designer implementers are maintained is
at theoretical science the theoretical
consequences of of complexities are
emergent properties so in human terms is
if you have one person taking a decision
it's usually very easy to understand why
the decision was taken you may not agree
with it but it's easy to figure out if
you have a large group of people they
tend to take this evening but no one
would have taken by themselves so it's
become very difficult to understand code
can end up and systems can end up like
this propagation of FX is clear you
change something on one side and
something pop up on the other side
incommensurate scaling is a interesting
phenomenon where I think the one of the
easiest example to understand is that if
you make a ship bigger at one point the
stopping distance will be larger than
the viewing distance so it will you can
never stop it in the sense that you
cannot see that you need to stop and
stop in the distance that you will cover
in the stopping distance because one
part of your system is growing at n
square and the other one is growing at
end or something like this and then you
have trade off meaning you cannot do
this and that you have to do this or
that most people associate complexity
with code which is very interesting
phenomenon so if if one of our bigger
companies get in trouble you can be
assured that the first project that they
will do is a modular ization projects
but it very very rarely comes from that
it's actually it's really more about how
you caught intertwined with other things
and that is mostly people and data it's
obviously better to not have caught
intertwined with too much other code but
that's really not that much of a problem
and code is normally easily replaced and
should be replaced easily most of the
time people stick around with code for
way too long oh it should never be
replaced in some cases I don't feel like
I need to replace the source code of LS
in UNIX it seems to work fine as is so
but you have to make the difference most
of the time so here I'll show you some
code that is well documented well modern
rise and everything and another piece of
code this is for more coding test that
we give to people so that that was one
candidate attempt well documented
absolutely perfect probably done in Java
or something except it failed most of
the tests and the one that was under
community and documented actually got 0
or 200 failures actually I should
everything this correctly so the small
one was actually working and you'll
never have to change it again so that
the theory is that if you muddle arise
if you create abstractions or
implementation and interface layering
like most computer system you have a
file system and then you have another
layer on top of it I araki you should be
okay and there's this legend that any
problem in a computer system can be
solved by adding a layer of indirection
in this particular case basically what
you do is you delay some decision and
you put a name on it and then normally
every it's a bit of a joke right I think
their mental seriously where thing is a
joke so that's what it is if you don't
know that try that in your Python
interpreter it actually works so here
what do you have you have an abstraction
which reduces complexity and in a
direction that makes it completely
increasing complexity right
you will never this is the only danger
of court right you've done something
that looks simple but in fact you've
made it virtually I mean it's only one
line but if you were to write your whole
code based on that import you could fly
around the world with it apparently
because you imported into gravity but
you have no idea what's going on under
your abstraction layer and you've if you
need to fly differently essentially
you've done nothing so you have to be
very careful when you take these
decisions and obviously the problem is
choosing the right then use whatever
word you want for for what creates
simplicity from the CEO of alternative
it's obviously where it breaks because
you can't you can't really do it and in
fact simplicity is the only solution to
complexity there is no there is no
alternative but that's obviously hard as
we said anyway and a guy called guys at
once at a complex system that works is
invariably fun to have evolved from a
simple system that works and the key
word is evolved so in order to make a
simple system or to avoid building
complex system which is often that thing
you should do is you have to design for
iteration and designing for iteration is
the definition of simplicity because you
allow people to do the right thing or
you allow yourself to do the right thing
in the future the data data is usually
the biggest source of complexity I'm
going to talk a little bit about a
different type of data I'll come to more
machine learning train data in a minute
data is usually the biggest source of
complexity because people do not
necessarily know that a structure and do
not really think enough about it your
code is usually useless without the data
especially if you're building an
e-commerce shop or something like this
sure the call is nice but you have to
write to a database you have to eat or a
database etc and usually because of
stupidity tools and frameworks that I
can never be tested we played clone
captain Singh it's at right Sarah so
typically as you know code and data are
really the same
at a very low level except that data is
a problem if you have a bug in your code
you can rerun your code after you fix
the bug if you have a bug in or you
introduce a bug in your data most likely
your whole data is corrupted so imagine
like you're running your code and every
bug destroys your code completely that's
usually what happens right and usually
when I have to fix a crisis it's usually
because of the way code and data
actually interacts that's the key
problem that don't forget I have to fix
complexity problems so people are not
able to change and do the right thing
and the reason why they're not able to
do the right thing is because of the way
code and data interact so aware it's a
guy we invented Quick Start is
simplicity if the unavoidable price we
have to pay for reliability but notice
the title of the paper data reliability
a very interesting concept it's a bit
antiquated the paper but basically talks
about exactly where complexity comes in
the data and why it's probably more
important than the complexity comes with
code but data can also be the source of
simplicity and that's probably why you
are here because you you obviously
interested in machine learning which is
not the same I guess of saving data to a
database for e-commerce purposes
previous slides were about read and
write data let's talk about weed and
train data so this is the i guess first
version of the spell corrector of google
its twenty one line of python i think
it's possible in some languages to write
it shorter in most languages
substantially longer but essentially if
given enough data this spell corrector
will mostly outperform anything else you
can you can write at the time it was
written it was written by Peter Novick
with was professor of artificial
intelligence and Stanford and the chief
scientist of Google most people did not
believe that such a thing would work
that it was possible to write something
so simple for something so complicated
like correct
the spelling of mostly every language
and so having enough data and this is
what we'll get to is could be also seen
as a greater simplifying of all so in
machine learning in the first phase the
one with the clever food usually one in
the next phase the one with the most
data wins and this is I'll show you the
full slide before but essentially these
are four different algorithm being
trained on half a million on this side
and then 1 million data point and you
know basically looking at this you say
well the guy with the red curve must be
the smallest guy because you know he's
got like close to eighty five percent
performance versus 75% for the blue guy
and there's a difference in complexity
if you actually look at these algorithm
the blue one is so trivial it's almost
difficult to believe and the right one
is very very smart but that's the
Academy game so if you're in University
you're going to get extra points for
moving from blue to red if you in
reality it doesn't matter because the
y-axis doesn't matter the x-axis matters
right and what happened on the x-axis is
you see that as you go to 1 billion
training words well well you can really
see that the blue line is catching up
but even if it didn't even if it didn't
you still have I can use the mouse but
you can see that it doesn't matter to be
the smartest guy that 500,000 versus the
dumbest guy at a billion right and I
think that this is a consistent
experience that we've experienced in the
last decade essentially because this is
really I mean they wrote this in 2001
but the truth is most people started to
realize this darling two thousand five
six seven eight etc and for most people
this is still the game that we have to
teach people that having more data and
using it correctly with very simple code
mostly always wins being clever doesn't
really help if you artificially reduce
yourself to the left side of the access
so in that sense data can be an immense
simplifier because you can write stuff
using enough data that does a lot more
stuff that you would have been able to
do before with less data and a lot more
code there's another way of coming up it
seems that the one we will win is the
one with the largest computer cluster
this is you know basically a typical
deep learning kind of a slide or
basically basis that you use for that
but to be able to use massive amount of
data and massive amounts of computing
power to calculate the simplest
representation of your data that
basically includes all of your training
data with in order to spacers way
possible is where it's what the world is
coming to and in a lot of ways this is
what simplicity is because it's able to
represent all your training data with oh
it learns how to represent your training
data with the least amount of well the
sparse linear combination of these bases
or learn which bases are able to do this
and so in a lot of ways data and machine
learning are contributing to simplicity
because at the end of the day then the
code that you need to run on top of that
data becomes relatively simple coming
back to the complexity people are
complex and when you intertwined people
code and data it usually gets worse so
this is more for your own benefit of
running a start-up or something it's
hard to make people simplify our versus
complex afire there's some kind of
inbuilt incentive to make them
complicated not sure where it comes from
but academia is a bit contributor to
that because as I showed earlier its
complexity wins in academia sometimes
and to make people simplify us very uh
Nigel in a sense because that's where
you really need leadership hard training
constant reviewing and brutal deadlines
and
jogos right so you cannot be too much in
la-la land to do this and rarely do the
import airball kind of thing that
simplifies that makes things easy but
obviously make the ultimate agility of
the company impossible later our
infrastructure is another complexity
generator especially if you intertwine
it with people software always has to
deploy it on infrastructure it's
virtually impossible to create simple
system that do not do that refuse
reliability because it's way too complex
right simplicity is the source of
reality reliability don't try to make a
complex system reliable it's simply too
expensive processes which is usually
where people go to when they start to
get faced with problems of complexity
carry enormous risk because they
essentially try to do the opposite of
what simplicity does which is people
tend to do the processing not the right
thing and if you implement a process and
then things change it's very difficult
to change course process and doing the
right thing at the same time you can
create good processes so it's not that
process are not good but then the good
processes are the one that actually test
for complexity and simplicity so
basically they should continuously test
your ability to change most process are
not doing this they're not testing your
ability to change they're actually
testing your ability to do the same
thing all the time communication another
recipe for reducing complexity in most
people's mind so people do stand-up stay
define protocol in interfaces on how to
do this in fact you should take a class
on distributed computer computing
because that's whether you like it or
not that's usually what people are doing
except they usually never taken a class
on it
and see how successful communication
protocol actually works and try to learn
from it this is a little bit of a joke
but this is often how communication
within companies actually work right you
have to decide whether you speak tcp or
UDP etc but often you have to repeat
yourself until people get it you cannot
just say it once and it sooner it works
so in summary again complexity is
whatever prevents you or someone else
from doing the right thing now in the
future and simplicity is the opposite
it's whatever helps you do the right
thing in the future we are hiring we
have a little bit of a coating test
their this is a more like a Turing test
to see if you can code we have many many
different position in the group from
single performer to directors of
engineering to whatever you can imagine
data scientists etc and I would love to
answer some questions if you have some
they could be about anything
so are there any questions for someone
you can ask what existing you can ask
about anything so yeah so that was very
simplified I guess so everything was
clear so I have a question yeah in your
experience with working with data
working with code was there any problem
which II which you thought was not
breakable into simpler the same problems
are simpler way to handle it all right
there are problems right now or machine
learning techniques right now which are
inherently too complex know so i think
that very often if you face and i'm not
talking about building a shop or
something like this right where maybe
the complexity arise from the number of
possible interaction that you have with
a consumer but let's take a more
theoretical problem that you want to
create a spell corrector an entity
recognizer or something that does
machine learning a thing most likely you
spend ninety percent of your work and
that's that's always been the case in
preparing your data or trying to get the
right feature right so before deep
learning most people actually spend
decades sometimes trying to find a
clever way to represent the data I think
the time spent on actual code in machine
learning is usually relatively small and
should probably be so is so I've never I
think that if you they used to be in the
80s these expert systems right where
people would essentially code if and
then statements forever to try to create
a system that would do medical diagnosis
or something but it's obvious that if
you have the right data and you've
prepared it correctly you can usually
easily beat the performance of the
system with you know one percent of the
code
so I don't think modularization of court
again in machine learning is is
something that makes a lot of sense like
you could have a 10 million line if then
statement expert system for the 80s
you're not going to make it better by
modernizing it it's not going to happen
and so usually trying to get the data in
the right while the right data and the
right size of the data is what you have
to shoot for yeah we have a one you
suggested it Molina is always better
than none ever hungry though he's not
true something bothering to set each end
and where do you go buy you some time
you think go for areas where is not so
moist or not and then based on your
bottom line one thing it depends a
little bit what you want to reach right
and i don't know i mean there's
different ways of interpreting what you
said right there are some algorithm
classes that if you feed them more data
and you start to run out of testing data
so you you you you by the way you are
over fit completely but that's not
necessarily bad because we sometimes
moving in two worlds where the training
data is the whole data right where
there's nothing really outside of the
data if you have full view about
something you know we leaving statistics
a little bit at the moment right we're
sampling is the problem and so in in
general i guess the only point I wanted
to make is that look at both access
whereas academia tend to focus on that
just one access saying there is a data
set for every researcher in the world
and that's the thing that's available
and the only thing that you can do is to
move along that y axis of performance I
think it underestimate that there are
some companies that have said well
maybe but let's see what happens when we
push 10 times more data into the thing
or a million times more data and usually
the return on the on the x-axis is is
quite dramatic one of the best paper on
this is is called the unreasonable
effectiveness of data by pinner Novick
it's the title is a bit of a joke on on
the paper called the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics which is
this strange phenomenon that that you
can explain the universe by a language
that we've basically invented mathematic
were discovered and data is a little bit
the same way and it has been
underestimated for many years simply
because and it's the same way its large
clusters of computer simply because
academia never necessarily had access to
immense datasets I think where you draw
the line is it depends very much on what
exactly you are trying to to do right
and what exactly do you define as good
enough performance because very often
you reach very quickly a point where
adding more data just doesn't improve
your numbers it's sometimes surprisingly
easy to get to that to that number but
it's still orders of magnitude higher
than what research typically use so i
would go both access night going in
islam so releases allegedly you said
quality the mid-ocean have a measure
yeah you prefer functional and ranges
distraction and their usability
revolution will I and show what imagine
different but ok well I think I without
getting into the you know not
necessarily religious but but kind of
really difficult war between functional
and non-functional etc it is you can
write things functionally that are not
really preparing for change and you can
write things in assembly language that
that's so well built that you can change
it anytime you want I mean you I I don't
think that's still the right abstraction
layer I think functional languages of a
little bit of an advantage in the sense
that they tend to minimize the to choose
what carefully but basically because a
function tends to behave the same way
every time you run it they do minimize
this problem that I mentioned with data
where you your code is essentially just
having a side effect on the database
right which is if you take a normal
framework type code in PHP Ruby Python
or whatever that deals with a database
back-end you can see the code as just
having a side effect on the database so
it's essentially unpredictable what the
code will be because it depends what the
database is the state and that introduce
a lot more complexity and I think that
people will you know we decide to solve
this in C or Python or some kind of
other functional of some functional
language I don't think it's the same
layer of discussion but functional as a
bit of an advantage because it's built
to us not assume these sort of thing so
yes slight preference but not necessary
functional language but function more
functional stuff like mapreduce and
stuff I got probably anyone else has
okay so as you said simplicity is very
difficult and everybody knows that in
companies you know the systems are
really complex and not not clean and all
that and now since you talked about it
and since you are aware of it I would
like to know what's the situation is
like at Buddha we enforce people to
think about it and try to turn it into a
more central systems well first of all
at bala we are very decentralized
organization so we unlike many big
companies we try to maintain every
single unit is really completely an
independent unit so we have no well I
shouldn't say no but we have a lot less
group-wide things like we would say okay
everyone has to adopt this language this
database this technique of doing things
so we tend to have extreme
contradictions in a group where one
group is completely not believing in
some kind of things and the other one is
actually completely believing in it
right so very so the group is is very
decentralized and when you decentralized
you don't tell people what to do because
if not you're not decentralized that's
kind of two decision so wherever you go
in the group you will find extremely
different levels of understanding and
and complexity stages the closer we have
out to the founding the less complexity
you usually have the closer you are to
the teenage years or 10 to 15 years
existence the more complexity you tend
to have and a lot more problems so maybe
I don't know if I should give you names
like this but you know I think zinc for
example is as past that problem faced
and others have not or just entering it
if you look at certain businesses we
have had for 40 to 50 years they
remarkably simple in the sense that i'm
sure there was a time in their existence
where they were
you know suffocating under complexity
but you know they survive and so they're
not at the top level Buddha is
remarkably simple and we don't have a
jold processes stand-up meetings I think
I talked to my boss once every three
months if at all and everything works
perfectly that way but so I think you
just a question of time mostly it's hard
for me to to find another variables that
matters in complexity most mostly is
when a company is between five and 15
years is when you'll see the most
complexity and mostly between I don't
know 220 and 200 people it's where you
see the most difficulties with this and
it has to do with the fact that they
emerge from 10 20 40 you know and and as
successful of course because if not they
don't reach that point and when you're
successful you have too many features
too many things too many products too
many people too many new people versus
all people all consulting so that sounds
like an evolutionary process absolutely
only the company's wish yeah yes
exceeded will survive right and if you
if you survive the initial phase it
means you are successful so the initial
phase is not complex right so you you've
been I've seen startups that are complex
at five people they do not go much
further than that right but does that
dude and then they're not they create
complexity and eventually if they
survive it they can become some very
long-lasting business I think that's
that's the normal evolution of a company
is if you survive that complexity phase
I mean think a little bit in terms of
teenage years right if if you if you
remain a teenager forever it's it's it
sounds nice but doesn't make your life
easier and companies are worse in that
way okay sounds like simplicity means
scalability as well you mentioned having
a process testing complexity or
simplicity are great can you speak of it
more about the tools that you use to do
this I don't know if it's a tool is that
it is a natural tendency when complexity
arises to create processes to try to
reduce it
so so typically if you let's say you
have a successful startup and it's run
by techies and founders and eventually
it becomes totally unmanageable because
al are just too crazy too much
complexity etc etcetera typically the
board will try to hire some adult
supervision of some sort and the first
thing that they will do is to try to
find processes right and what is the
process is well think of McDonald's
right it's like if everyone at
McDonald's were doing burgers like they
like them it wouldn't be McDonald's
because you would never know what you
get right so they do a process and I
said this is the way we do burgers and
in a lot of ways in companies that's
that's what management at least tries to
do to define processes that determines
how you do stuff the problem with that
is that these process can add to the
complexity because they simply determine
how you do stuff but if changes occur
the process can become the problem right
so the process are not proceed upon but
but if changes occur and you know you
can't deal with it so maybe an example
for management although it's not
directly what process but it tells you a
bit to thinking so it's a bit of a story
/ joke there's a there's a wicked
psychologist or very nasty psychologist
and he's doing experiments on monkeys
and he has four monkeys in the room one
ladder and a banana and so the first
monkey goes up the ladder but scientists
as highs cold water and just sprays the
monkey and the other monkey's second
monkey goes up same spraying method etc
they stop going up right now they switch
one monkey so there's a new guy the new
guy goes up the ladder get sprayed all
the otherwise get sprayed etc you know
after a while new monkey comes in monkey
tries to go up the ladder gets beaten up
by the other monkey's right eventually
all the original monkeys have been
replaced no one has ever get unsprayed
new monkey comes then tries to go up
gets beaten up and then you say what the
hell's going
here's as well that's the way we do
things around here right but companies
are like that right i mean don't
underestimate the fact that
psychologically the ability of one
person to change 50 people is virtually
zero right so if you have a process in
place that says this is the way we do
things around here eventually you're
going to get smart guys coming and
saying I think we should do things
differently it's not going to work
they're going to get virtually beaten up
and then so that you have to always see
okay we get a new process tell me how
this process will help us change when we
need to change right or tell me how it's
going to create the opposite so how it's
going to make it difficult for us to
change because no matter how complex you
are doing stuff right if you're able to
change it it is not or complicated like
you know you could program your whole
thing in assembly language and it's all
graphic and it's difficult and it's non
functional and it's horrifically
procedural it's going to even go to
statements called jumps right but it
doesn't matter if you can change it
again it's not a problem
okay so let's thank our speakers jumbled
once more
you
you